think about it yeah look at look I'll
give a primary example Jeremy Meeks
criminal oh his monk shot came out do
you remember this this guy's Market came
up all of a sudden all these girls like
oh he's so hot dude
this guy came out of prison and became a
models have 30 more children than
non-felons so when girls say they like
nice guys they don't
but I think I think we've made nice guys
to feel like they they don't have the
confidence to come up and talk to us
because we've made them feel like that
because we're constantly choosing bad
guys
don't even want the modern women they
just yeah they just had enough of them
men gone their own way oh yeah big towel
that's it and they just go because
they've had enough I think some nice
guys know that some women can be
absolutely quickly you said you said the
onus isn't on it's not I don't think the
owners of um guys who don't have
confidence to speak women's on women
that is your personality trait and
that's got nothing to do with me you
know
because I think I think this
conversation is like we tend to
generalize a lot and I get it because I
guess that's what is in your in your
view so it's easy to generalize but I
think there are nice guys who because
reading truly it's not like this there's
a lot of nice guys that are single yeah
they're getting girls yeah and some of
them are committed in relationships I
think it's just I think it's easy for us
to obviously say that you know we can
talk about certain type of girls and
blah blah because that's really what's
in our view but I don't believe if I
meet a guy who's shy and whatever I
don't believe that women have women I
think he's he's um personality anyway
he's an introvert or he's shy anyway and
maybe that is heightened when he meets
Other Woman and he can't doesn't have
the confidence but I don't think that
onus is on women making him shy it's not
it's not it's not it's not the onuses on
women it's like we're responsible for
the men that we pick yeah yeah so I
agree with that part but she was saying
how um she thinks that guys are like the
shy guys they don't have the common
approaching me because
is partially but it's partially our
fault because feminism had this whole me
too movie yeah and so and so like we're
complaining like they're shy because
they don't know if they're going to be
me too if they approach the wrong girl
no no seriously there's there's
a YouTuber that just came out where he
he approached a girl in public and she
literally called the the Park police on
him and this was in 2022. yeah but there
was guys that were shy before the
meeting was started
wait how old are you I'm 27. like so me
too was what five seven years ago yeah
how long were you really in the dating
game yeah that's the thing because I've
got another life experience okay
actually I'm gonna ask Auntie dude
Auntie do you feel like men approach
women more or less now when they
approach women less now because women
look more Fierce they wear more paint
and because the men are scared
because nowadays it takes a couple of
rare things to happen for all men to be
labeled so now you don't even know
whether to approach a woman or not
because you don't know whether she's
going to say that you're harassing her
leave her alone and sometimes you might
hear this one a woman might just a man
might just want to say excuse me love do
you know that no another time take your
watch a girl drops something and I've
gone to give it back and she gave me
some dirty look I was like so I took it
I snapped it was Oyster card I snapped
and went and went my way yeah okay and
that's that's why a lot of men just
don't approach women I don't always like
your personality trait you can be quite
shy and introvert me personally I'm very
very shy but when you are in a situation
where you feel comfortable you can come
out of your shell and with some guys you
know with some girls they can come out
their shell whereas other women have
made them feel no you stay shy because
women
I don't think that I think guys will
approach you if they feel good about
themselves so if they feel like they're
you know put pushing gym or whatever
that to build their own self-confidence
I I know guys that feel good about
themselves like they're like yeah I'm
good looking I go to the gym you know
I'm a nice person and he won't approach
a girl but he'll look at a girl and be
like no I won't approach her because we
we like or that girl looks so good and
no no no no no
this is the death of femininity I think
a lot more women are masculine back in
the day women would signal and even when
we had kit on the other day he he
educates women yeah he educates women
how to signal to allow a man to to feel
comfortable enough to get um to approach
again
maybe the problem is men aren't actually
looking for women's signal before
they're approaching so when a girl is
now calling Paw Patrol is because she's
not signaled to you she's not showed you
she's any interested you don't know what
her relationship status is and maybe
wait for the cues for a woman yeah
can I say this I think women in body
masculinity more now
no no but look at this check this go on
I don't know if anyone else uses tfl
regularly maybe I'm poor but you know go
on the tube you see the advert I I'm
staring harassment
it puts men on edge yeah
but if you flip it to like countries
where there isn't that a lot of men take
advantage so it's not these aren't put
in there for women do the majority of
men are the majority of men the men
you're describing
sorry uh the majority of men Dominion
describing so the men you're saying that
take advantage is that in the country
like where this isn't the social norms
where you have time is that the majority
of men
sorry is that the majority of yeah go on
do you think the majority of men are
doing that in those countries in those
countries what going up to women
unsolicited yeah 100
and they're grabbing girls and they're
the majority the majority of men in
those countries are grabbing girls 100
so the majority of men in those
countries are committing assault yes
that's your view on man no no that's not
my view on men that's cultural
differences in my country even where
women's rights are not like well I'm not
I'm not here saying women are equal to
me I'm saying but if a woman doesn't
want to be touched don't touch her
that's even a religious side if you
don't touch it I'm with you yeah so in
them countries where work countries like
even parts of Asia Africa can you name
them
I've had men approach me millions and
I've said no no no approaching me you
said you said wait wait you said you
said grabbed they were they were right
even in Dubai they grabbed one of my
friends I've been to Dubai I was fine I
had no issues yeah exactly what I'm
saying again and I went with my Twitter
and I went with my family family sorry
yeah
but also and again maybe this is where
the cultural differences are when it
comes to even like me traveling as an
Asian woman they don't see me as my
British passport they see me as an Asian
woman if I go to Dubai they see me as a
Bangladeshi woman and they will take
advantage of that thinking I'm a
Bangladeshi woman it's just interesting
um because I know a couple people from
those countries and they don't actually
have the same views as you
grew up in the like like um you said
well I think you said Morocco yeah
I'll say this
the context on in which this happened
you were on holiday right and you're
saying that people grabbed you what was
the context of that group no I'm not
saying that they're constantly grabbing
this approach they're trying to talk
yeah but are you but can I say as a
Moroccan were you a tourist were you in
a tourist area were you in the Medina
were they approaching you to sell you
things what no I'll just walk in the
beach I was walking the beach even if
it's a touristic area what I'm saying is
some countries like even just say when I
go Bangladesh and I'm not a tourist yeah
and I'm in my own country clothes
everything guys will still feel like
they can they have a right to come and
speak to you okay okay
yeah yeah I'm not saying it's wrong I'm
saying again look at social cues if like
you said the guys teaching girls what
signaling is if she's not making eye
contact if she's not don't maybe don't
approach her especially and that's how
they make guys
do you see how this is kind of like the
situation that I was describing because
you're kind of like me tooing these guys
because they approached okay can I just
say as a victim who has been sexually
abused as a child it's yeah it is deep
it is deep and I don't want if I don't
want you accessing my personal space
don't do it
it's not just me too no I talk to
everyone I'm a very social being Eddie
knows I'm very social you trying to
cross that line no like if I've not
necessarily the guy's fault because if
he I personally myself I've been through
the same thing but I would never be able
to look at a guy and say you know it's
your fault if I'm getting mad that
you're coming up and to talk to me I'm
not saying I get mad he doesn't he
doesn't know what's happened to you so
he shouldn't be able to feel like too
shy to still come true I will never call
a man or call police on a man trying to
say hello to me at the park I will smile
and I'll go on my way if he is now
following me and trying to take
advantage of that situation yes I will
panic and that's again my traumas I'll
Panic if he understands oh she doesn't
want to say hello and he Minds business
there's no problem I think that's what
that's what it is but you said the
majority of men are grabbing girls in
countries
and that's and that's where like I have
an issue with that because I don't think
you're correct I know people from those
countries and they would not say the
same thing so it's interesting to me
that's your view because it to me that's
like that's like your view on men
they're not saying
I'm not saying that it doesn't happen
I'm not saying it doesn't happen we're
saying it's not the majority okay it
happens
and it might be my figure it might be my
and that's why again I don't like to
when I go especially abroad I don't wear
clothes that will extinuate my figure as
much or my skin because I like to
protect myself yeah it might be that
they find me attractive and they want to
maybe every God doesn't experience that
but every time I go out I do get
approached or I do get spoken to and I
have to now I smile it's not like I'm
calling police but I'll be like no sorry
I'm not interested or okay yeah no you
know I'm not single and I get I guess
every girl says that to you guys I'm not
single then they'll be like oh what so
yeah you can't have a side boyfriend
yeah
it's just a problem exactly I don't but
I don't think like if a guy's persistent
like I'm not I don't think that's that
bad like no one's saying it's bad it's
like I don't I don't think he should
grab you I think that's like okay don't
don't but like you're telling me you you
went to this country and every single
guy you saw are like let's say so the
majority so it's a six out of ten guys
you saw grabbed you no not grab they
will approach me okay but approaching is
an assault no it's not that it's an
assault but it could lead hold up if I
keep smiling and entertaining it and not
saying putting my boundary on he might
think oh she's interested and it's very
hard for sometimes I feel like we say
yes just because it's easier like I take
guy's number just because that's not
their fault like to me like if a guy
approaches me again again like it's
annoying but who cares like I I've been
in like I went to Martinique I don't
know if you've heard of it yeah it's
nice it's nice and like guys there
they're like at this beach would like
come up to me and I'm like who cares I'd
be like go away okay but maybe um sorry
babes I think it can be intimidating I
think the way a person can approach you
like I think some people I think it
depends on each Essence like how you are
I guess but I think sometimes the way
even the way a guy will approach you can
make you uncomfortable I'm a confident
person
and I've had guys approach me that's
made me feel intimidated I've given guys
my number just so that this interaction
can end I've had some I went to a party
one time and the guy was like I think it
was a security at the venue and I left
and I didn't realize he was following me
and I'm walking down a dark Road I get
in my car thankfully as soon as I get in
the car I lock the doors I lock the door
he's like he's like oh without trying to
get my attention I was like oh I'm not
interested because this is I feel unsafe
in this situation he stood there he
stood there getting his phone out like
he's talking to me I'm looking at him
like bro and I was annoying because I
was in a tight space I couldn't just
kind of just drive off so I think some
guys it can be like it's just the way
they approach they don't approach you in
a way that makes people come comfortable
I'm with you I'm saying a majority
that's my that's my problem is when and
you guys are saying that's the majority
of men so that means six out of ten guys
are approaching you in that way they're
not saying it doesn't have countries
we're just saying it's not the majority
maybe like I'm using the words
I'm using the words that you said okay
the majority of men will physically grab
me but they will try come in my personal
space and they might try to put their
hand around me they might try to I just
think what what world are you in that's
six out of ten men are approaching well
maybe again maybe it's a young lady the
young lady at the end I don't know her
name the young lady at the end I've had
lots of friends go to Morocco and
depending on where they go it depends on
how they get treated and the tourist
areas people approach people and when
you travel so it might be the majority
in that particular area
no but you're saying the majority of men
in Morocco no no
in this country we have these
Protections in other countries we don't
yeah and when I've traveled to other
countries it's obviously going to be
touristy areas men have been quite in my
space and then I asked you is it the
majority majority of men in that time
have been in my face I said in those
countries and you said yes well I
promised to God we will clip this I
can't speak
so can I say that I do think that as
much that she can go to Morocco I can go
to Morocco we go to the exact same place
different experiences so I think each
person's experience that whatever they
say whatever conversation they have is
going to be based off their experiences
it could be a thing where when she does
go out maybe she goes out seven days a
week maybe four hours seven days a week
she feels harassed by men and that's
that's her and we can travel in the same
place
this is dangerous
that that that is dangerous and feel
harassed were you harassed yes feeling
harassed is not harassing I don't know
if I feel harassed because I've been
harassed yeah what what is her what is
harassment being arrested what is
feeling harassed feeling you could be
walking down the road and the man could
be walking behind you and you turn right
he turns right he turned if he turns
left you might feel her ass he's
actually going the same direction you
are okay and then you can be you the man
could follow you talking to you excuse
me can I have your number can I have
your number touch you can have your
number following you that is being hurt
okay that's what happens the being
harassed happens